hey it's your officer Boston what are
you doing man
Warriors
okay making sure the check engine so
you're going at least 90 on pip I was
going none you're going at least nine
times 80 yards which is still hot but
I'm trying to just get a check engine
light I was trying to accelerate quick
more than going fast you know what I
mean okay sit tight I'll be right back
161 10 20 something to Georgia
161 it's going to be zero five nine zero
two six six nine three repeating zero
five nine zero two six six nine three
he's gonna drill
anyone else no just one
hey step out the car for me
on your back oh you're on the Rest For
What
for what reckless driving
are you serious yep yes
your car yeah I own a car dealership
okay where uh Snellville Georgia no
Georgia Auto Brokers okay well y'all
seriously arresting me yes you don't get
to go 90 in the 45 mile yeah I was just
trying to test the car for a minute
I was just trying to test the car for a
mission
okay at least find somebody and pick up
the car
1611.95 yeah this vehicle is soaking
it's somewhere in The Pick of the car
go ahead spread your legs for me yes sir
do you have anything on your pockets
like the Poke sticker stab me no I have
a phone I have a wallet I have uh
Smokies are actually in the car I have a
vape
can I get somebody to pick up the car at
least
yeah you can place that phone call I'll
let you make that phone call yes sir
who are you gonna call and where they
come from uh I'm gonna try to call my
girlfriend
hey Marina
she's actually on the phone right now
you can turn it up for me please
yeah
yes sir
I'm really arresting me for this yeah
yeah going 95 in the 45. I was literally
testing the car for emissions
please don't tell stop with that okay
you're not you're not you're not driving
95 miles per hour it was almost 100
miles per hour and just to test driving
cars that there's no way there's other
ways to test a car
you have a dealership you know this yeah
exactly so don't don't say that you're
gonna drive 100 miles per hour just to
test drive there's no way accelerate
turn the mic off no turn it back on yeah
and then just turn the volume up okay
hey Marina yeah yeah I need um someone
to pick my car up I'm going to jail
they're arresting me for this
I don't know apparently reckless driving
but
I don't know bro
can you call like Michael or someone
I think they're in the area
yeah you could come
it's uh the Goodwill I think you might
have passed it Goodwill off if you happy
Goodwill off of PIV
all right thank you
so do you mind waiting around for her
I guess I should have called and gotten
the ECA but huh I think they were like
close by he was the one who was racing
and I'm almost certain
or he wasn't racing but I'm all certain
she was behind him willing to go on the
speed limit
your dad's calling
I had uh
what's up
yeah
Goodwill
Goodwill off of PIV Peachtree Industrial
Boulevard
that baby
go for 161.
yeah
is that your girlfriend yeah no that's
actually not I'm not sure who that is oh
actually I think that might be my cousin
but okay yeah
okay I gotta go ahead yeah
no
yeah
hey how are y'all doing
he's okay he's he has someone coming to
pick him up were you guys with him
tonight yeah uh yeah I was with him but
I'm not sure what okay speak to me real
quick if you don't mind
um
in a second okay okay cool
he called his girlfriend but if you guys
okay which one of you guys is going to
be driving how old is my father okay was
he drinking tonight or no because I'm
trying to understand why he's just
flying down the road no it's just it's a
fast car I know that's why I wanted from
one or I'll call him I'm on the phone
with him oh okay okay why he's driving
with a dealer tag uh he owns a car
dealership
yeah if he owns a car dealership he
needs to have a dealer tag not not a
test drive tag
all right which one of you guys is going
to be driving the vehicle okay so I am
gonna need your license real fast sure
uh just please have a liquor machine
control the vehicle over here
huh you want to be so bad he wanna what
go number one
he's gonna have to wait
he's gonna have to wait okay
well he was driving somewhere so
I don't think it was that bad you know
just now that he's in Hancock now he
wants to pee so he could have stopped
somewhere on the way you know if he
needed to use the restroom real bad but
now he's gonna have to wait until we to
finish
one more time
yeah he'll take everything everything
he advised on the bin right yeah he's
the negative 10 29 out of California uh
do you have the wallet as well no send
some pictures just in case he went from
anybody else
is there a wallet as well uh no there's
just a phone in his ID I didn't see a
wallet maybe he's in the car
you see that so he can spit tonight
he'd probably get out yeah I mean it's
it's going to be a couple hours it might
even be one hour right depending how
busy they are too it's going to be two
misdemeanors right reckless driving and
uh driving with unregistered vehicle
there's two misdemeanors you'll probably
be out in an hour or two hours maybe
right the biggest thing is you can't be
going 90 on this road so
I don't know
and you all you own the dealer with him
no no no no I'm not okay she's his
father
okay I'm gonna go ahead and write what I
need to write if you want to go ahead
and take to me okay sure everyone's good
to go okay thank you very much thank you
thank you let's go
foreign
California
amsterdamentally
yeah
what year is the vehicle
[Music]
cover
yeah
[Music]
you need anything else man